we'll ask you the same question over and
over and over again what kind of
questions do you want people to ask you
so you don't have to answer the same
question over and over so Steve this is
literally the question I hate the
most really I'll tell I'll explain in a
minute literally you I would have
preferred you asked me the same cliche
question that I've been yes I'll tell
you why when you're answering people's
questions you need to provide them value
not your self value there's nothing I
want to be asked all I want to do is
give people what their question is I
don't mind answering the same question
over and over you know why we have 7 to
11 basic themes that are us up
right